la question que je vous pose vous pouvez
me dire non vous pouvez me dire non je
me sens pas de leur parler ce soir
est-ce que vous voulez avoir une
entrevue avec Pierre et Marie
ce soir Pierre et Marie merci Pierre et
Maryse qui peuvent venir est-ce qu'on
peut les installer s'il vous plaît
j'espère que ça va bien se passer voilà
parce que Nadia franchement j'étais
touché par contre
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
de les embrasser
vous avez pas le droit d'être là vous
avez pas le droit de vous adresser à la
parole déjà parce qu'on n'est pas
représenté par un avocat Nadia les alors
donc ça voilà Pierre et Marie on va on
va écouter Nadia ce qu'elle a à vous
dire déjà parce que je pense c'est voilà
Nadia dites-nous
alors moi monsieur madame Garcia en fait
je vous connais pas du tout vous m'avez
fait confiance à travers votre agence
d'accord
simplement aujourd'hui en fait je suis
venue m'expliquer m'excuser puisque ça a
pris des proportions telles que j'ai
tout essayé avec l'agence en lui
expliquant elle est revenue par reparti
elles m'ont quand j'ai demandé des mails
aujourd'hui voilà l'explication on va
faire on va synthétiser moi je ne savais
pas tout ce que vous subissiez d'accord
vous êtes dans votre vos droits d'accord
moi je suis locataire moi j'ai fait
confiance à une agence tout simplement
d'accord tout simplement pourquoi
c'était l'agence j'aimerais vraiment que
je sais que vous avez énormément de
colère énormément de frustration
j'aimerais vraiment j'aimerais que ce
soit on soit calme on voit Nadia dans
quel disposition elle est venue
j'aimerais vraiment perdre et Maryse
qu'on trouve une solution ce soir pour
que vous soyez heureux voilà et que
Nadia on va essayer de voir ce qu'on
peut faire pour elle mais je veux pas
qu'il y ait d'invective que ça voilà ça
part je vous dis Maryse et Pierre Nadia
est-ce que aujourd'hui vous êtes prêtes
à quitter le logement oui ça fait
longtemps que j'essaie de le quitter
vous savez donc vous essayez de trouver
un nouveau logement c'est ça ça fait
longtemps est-ce que l'agence vous la
trouvez quelle agence l'agence que vous
avez pas demandé à l'agence qui vous a
trouvé ce logement de vous trouver une
autre alors le jour où elle me l'a
proposé rapidement quand elle m'a dit
ils sont revenus elle m'a proposé un T1
un peu moins cher que ce que j'ai mais
un terrain j'ai une fille j'ai une ado
aujourd'hui Pierre et Maryse qu'est-ce
que vous avez à dire à Nadia vraiment on
soit
on essaie d'avancer
il y a une décision de justice ok il y a
eu un procès nous l'avons gagné donc
déjà c'est fini
ça a été rendu on a gain de cause déjà
c'est une bonne chose ensuite ce que je
veux dire à Madame c'est que depuis deux
ans allez on va dire dedans des animaux
s'en foutent depuis 2 ans elle a eu le
temps de de de de chercher quelque chose
ensuite on est passé en procès qu'on a
gagné elle a eu encore quatre mois de
sursis et toujours pas d'appartement il
y a un an et demi on lui a fait une
proposition cette dame à travers nos
avocat lui a dit Madame eh oui madame
vous êtes d'accord d'accord si vous
voulez on est face tout voilà
refusé et le loyer il y a 1000 € de
loyer chez lui on oublie
on oublie tout vous partez ce qu'on veut
c'est notre maison on a le départ alors
attendez Nadia n'a pas donné ça
aujourd'hui Nadia il y a alors je vous
dis il y a eu il y a eu depuis il y a eu
des choses Nadia vous a vu elle a pu
mettre un visage sur sur des des
propriétaires et je pense que Nadia
comme nous l'a dit elle a été
extrêmement touchée de voir comme nous
tous comme toute la France entière quand
on vous a vu pierre et Maryse comme elle
a dit on a envie de vous faire des
bisous on a envie que vous soyez heureux
et Nadia elle a eu cette réaction dès
que vous êtes rentré à la vie j'ai envie
j'ai envie de leur faire des bisous
alors après après après c'est vrai que
voilà ça effacé par une agence Nadia
peut-être qu'on vous voyant voilà
aujourd'hui elle a vu dans quelle
détresse vous étiez aujourd'hui Nadia je
pense peut-être envie de tourner la page
tourner la page Nadia est-ce que moi je
suis prêt à vous aider aussi pour que
vous partiez le plus vite possible
peut-être à essayer de vous aider
pendant un mois le temps que vous
trouviez quelque chose pour que vous
partiez le plus rapidement possible et
que Pierre et Marie puisse des ce
weekend ou dès demain voilà dès vendredi
puissent retrouver ou voilà vous faites
un des on essaie d'organiser un
déménagement assez rapide on peut même
s'en occuper tout est à moi d'accord
très bien donc voilà et que voilà il y a
quelques affaires non mais voilà Marie
c'est Pierre et qu'on puisse voilà
est-ce qu'on peut pas organiser ça à la
limite on peut vous venir en aide
pendant un mois nous pour le temps que
vous trouviez quelque chose comme ça
pierre et Maryse il retrouve leur
logement dès demain qu'il puisse passer
le week-end dans leur maison et que vous
on puisse éventuellement voilà vous
trouvez quelque chose pendant un mois
qu'on puisse voilà vous aider pendant un
mois le temps que vous trouviez autre
chose est-ce que c'est quelque chose de
recevable
Nadia je peux pas parler en ce moment
ne vous inquiétez pas je ne m'adresse
après alors à moi
ça vous pose pas de difficulté que je
puisse m'être humain vous savez que
j'étais présent donc si vous voulez pas
me rencontrer
allez on va pas rentrer là-dedans mettre
aujourd'hui si vous voulez
la réalité c'est que je suis content
qu'il soit présent finalement je t'ai
d'accord tu aucune difficulté un
dialogue qui peut s'installer je pense
que la décision de Nadia est prise elle
va vouloir quitter le logement et elle
veut quitter ce logement moi j'ai envie
oui mais Nadia elle va pas le quitter
elle il faut qu'elle le guide Nadia
est-ce qu'on peut nous avec la
production vous aider pendant un mois
pour que vous puissiez vous retourner et
pour que Pierre et Marie puisse entrer
dans leur appartement dès demain ou des
samedis maximum est-ce que c'est
possible il faut quand même voir
l'appartement
voilà ça m'arrive les travaux je
viendrai les faire j'ai une pour une
personne je suis inquiétez pas voilà
l'offre qu'on a fait alors c'est quoi et
pourquoi ils ont fait pierre moi je
pense que Pierre et Marie ce comme a dit
Maryse aujourd'hui on remet tout à zéro
Nadia elle vous a vu sur les écrans elle
a pu mettre un visage sur ses
propriétaires elle a pu et Nadia elle a
un cœur je le vois Nadia voilà elle
s'est dit aujourd'hui elle s'est dit moi
quand elle vous a vu elle s'est dit
comme la plupart des français elle s'est
dit bah moi ça peut être mes parents ça
peut être mes grands-parents ça peut
être des gens de ma famille et les voir
dans un tel désarroi et bah ça me touche
et Nadia aujourd'hui elle a pris sa
décision elle veut quitter l'appartement
Nadia
quand est-ce que vous voulez le quitter
là vous me prenez un cours je suis
tellement perturbée depuis
ma fille
je pense que c'est
elle ne vit plus dans l'appartement
depuis 3 jours voilà
ce qu'on a mis notre adresse et j'ai
reçu des menaces donc ce que vous allez
pas attendre novembre la décision de
l'appel puisque en plus il est pas
suspensif aujourd'hui vous vous en vrai
on attend on attend la signature voilà
du préfet mais aujourd'hui Nadia moi
j'en appelle à votre cœur à votre voilà
aujourd'hui et je comprends que vous
aussi le problème c'est que Nadia il va
falloir qu'elle se loge aussi on va pas
laisser Nadia d'or parce qu'après on va
le problème de Nadia qui va se retrouver
dehors je vous dis c'est pour ça on vous
propose peut-être de vous aider nous
avec la production non mais un mois ou
deux peut-être Nadia pour que vous
puissiez vous retourner est-ce que ça ça
peut aider pour aider pierre et Maryse
pour qu'ils puissent retrouver leur
logement dès ce week-end je vous
remercie pour votre proposition il y a
deux choses qui qui à mon avis vont être
compliqué
lundi matin à 10h
c'est magnifique
aujourd'hui c'est pas maintenant qu'on
va changer non reste dans le bras
d'accord la loi c'est la loi si cette
dame là est excusée la semaine prochaine
si elle est pas expulsée on ira
refusé notre proposition Nadia prof vous
avez refusé la proposition Nadia
vous voyez bien que aujourd'hui on le
voit Nadia elle a envie de régler
l'affaire ben moi je trouve pas de ouf
vous avez envie de régler l'histoire
aujourd'hui
j'étais venu m'expliquer m'excuser et là
si vous voulez
vous excuser vous avez vous avez qu'à
faire ce qu'il fallait faire quand vous
a dit de partir quand vous a fait la
proposition voilà pourquoi vous avez dit
non vous avez
conseillé juridiquement le congé avec
conseillé et vous avez simplement de
votre fille le décision de la décision
de justice
Nadia la décision de justice du 28 avril
2002 il est expressément dit au départ
que c'était une reprise pour congés pour
y habiter et à la fin par ses motifs
pour le vent pour le bas
jusqu'au bout pour vendre pour vente et
moi si
c'est écrit madame je n'invente rien
c'est un jugement aujourd'hui
vous allez voir donc le préfet lundi
matin donc ça a bougé voilà donc ça a
bougé il vous a appelé à la suite de
l'émission
je peux pas vous dire tout tout ce qu'il
a raconté
à 10h et je vous garantis que ça ça va
aller ça va on espère alors Nadia
finalement Cyril
ce qui me désole c'est que
déontologiquement j'ai un vrai souci
parce que messieurs ne sont pas
accompagnés de leur avocat et c'est très
compliqué pour moi d'accord
[Musique]
je ne peux malheureusement pas répondre
à tout ça c'est la première chose après
encore une fois comme la vie Nadia elle
est venue pour deux choses
exactement parce qu'elle a bien une
chance j'aimerais bien qu'on entend de
Nadia oui un couple qui est aujourd'hui
est en détresse c'est ça mais il faut
pas oublier aujourd'hui je sais pas
parce que Monsieur et Madame sont en
détresse elle comprend elle entend elle
le respecte mais il faut aussi lui
trouver une solution c'est ce qu'on dit
parce qu'elle pourrait aussi aujourd'hui
arriver dans votre émission en les
mettant en mettant en avant finalement
que le préfet pour l'instant n'a rien
fait ou lundi on n'est pas lundi
aujourd'hui on est jeudi après on n'est
pas lundi il y a pas de décision
d'expulsion aujourd'hui avec une
autorité de la force publique a été
ordonnée et à côté de ça il y a un appel
qui va passer ici
on a envie que personne soit dans la rue
je vous le dis on va voir ils vont voir
le préfet moi j'ai envie que Nadia nous
dise qu'elle avait à nous dire et qu'on
la laisse parler ce qu'elle a à vous
dire
parce que Nadia elle est aussi danger
sur les réseaux voilà après moi
vous savez que Maryse et Pierre j'ai été
très très touché par votre affaire c'est
pour ça que je veux absolument la régler
que vous soyez heureux et que vous
puissiez retrouver votre maison mais on
va la laisser à dire voilà Nadia allez
allez-y parler
dites ce que vous avez à directeur
studio c'est nous qu'on a souffert c'est
nous qu'on a souffert c'est tout Nadia
Cyril la souffrance des hommes n'empêche
pas la souffrance des autres et
finalement j'allais dire c'est pas parce
que d'un côté il y a une chose que
l'autre côté il y en a pas une autre non
plus aujourd'hui si vous voulez je pense
qu'elle n'est pas en mesure de pouvoir
vous répondre à l'instant on va essayer
de trouver une solution comme je l'ai
dit moi je suis tout à fait on veut pas
que Nadia aussi voilà
on comprend voilà Nadia il faut pas non
plus qu'elle soit qu'elle se fasse
lyncher
Nadia elle a quand même une fille elle a
un fils voilà donc aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que je demandais à Nadia de
s'exprimer comme ça elle clôture
l'affaire et qu'elle dise bien ce
qu'elle dise que c'est la première fois
qu'elle rencontre Pierre et Maryse
ce que Nadia vous sentez de de nous dire
quelques mots
bien non
en fait j'étais venue les dire mais vous
avez été coupé dans votre élan
ce que vous voulez rencontrer Pierre et
Marie ils ont plus pour
ici mais ça fait 8 et moi et des mois
que j'avais envie mais je ne savais pas
comment faire puisque c'est une agence
qui la gère et que je n'avais plus
contact avec l'agence de toute façon je
reçois quand même les quittances de
loyer avec l'undemnité puisque je suis
occupante bien entendu sans droit et
titre ça je l'entends bien mais alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans quelle
disposition
puisque c'est devenu de toute façon
non ça fait deux ans et demi déjà parce
que j'aime cet appartement
bien sûr madame qui est-ce qu'il
aimerait pas merci je paye un loyer
900 euros
donc voilà aujourd'hui vous voulez
partir oui bien entendu que je veux
partir sur toi après les menaces et les
injures et tout ce qui se passe là la
médiatisation moi je tombe des nuls
l'appartement voilà aujourd'hui comment
il est Madame voilà
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est une
bonne nouvelle
à moi très peu mais c'est voilà
l'appartement et j'ai tout laissé je
vous allez retrouver
vos vêtements j'ai vos papiers non non
nos vêtements il y en a pas très bien
merci ça m'arrive et Pierre on a
l'impression que la peut pas se régler
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle la faire
devrait se régler assez vite Nadia on
espère vous aussi vous allez trouver un
logement quand même parce qu'on veut pas
voilà on pense à votre fille on pense à
vous ce que vous disiez très juste
finalement il faut que tout le monde
trouve parce que d'abord
il y a une épée dans mon casier sur sa
tête avec cette poudre matière mais nous
on espère Nadia le travail elle paye un
loyer elle a une fille on espère juste
que Pierre et Maryse ils retrouvent leur
appartement c'était la semaine prochaine
et que Nadia ne soit pas à la rue avec
sa fille et qu'elle puisse voilà voilà
s'en sortir et je vous le dis 6 points
aller plus vite voilà on peut aider et
ben on le fera avec plaisir sachez-le
parce qu'on veut aussi pierre et Maryse
retrouve leur maison au plus vite donc
voilà si on peut aider on le fera pour
que vous gagnez un petit peu de temps
sachez qu'on le fera Nadia voilà je vous
le dis on le fera et je vous le dis
maître voilà ça va très bien merci en
tout cas à vous